Speaker 1: Hey, I love it when these wacky right
wingers turn on each other. And Donald Trump
is now furious with Kellyanne Conway, his long
time adviser. Kellyanne Conway has now made a
number of statements which have infuriated Donald
Trump. There's a Politico article about this.
Former President Donald Trump is denying a
key anecdote from Kellyanne Conway's book,
saying he would have banished Kellyanne from
his inner circle if she had ever told him he
lost the 2020 presidential election. So what's
at issue here is that Kellyanne Conway has now.
Kellyanne Conway wrote, I had already said
publicly what I'd said privately to George
his daily day. Oh, well, this actually isn't
the right thing. So where is this? Here.
It might not the quote might actually not be in
this article. Kellyanne Conway writes in her book,
among other things, that she was one of the
first people to tell Trump, You lost. You just
you lost. And that's it. You lost the election.
And Trump is now saying that that's not true.
Trump posted on his platform truth, social.
Speaker 2: Truth, essential.
Speaker 1: Quote. Kellyanne Conway never told
me that she thought we lost the election.
If she had, I wouldn't have dealt with her
any longer. She would have been wrong. Could
go back to her crazy husband. Kellyanne Conway
husband is anti-Trump Republican George Conway.
Back to the quote. Writing books can make people
say some very strange things. I wonder why got 12
million more votes than we did the first time?
The most votes by far of any sitting president.
The election was rigged. They used COVID to
cheat and steal. And the evidence is massive and
indisputable. C 22,000 mules, which of course is
the completely bogus and widely debunked. Dinesh
D'Souza I can't even call it a documentary because
it doesn't document anything real. Let's call it
a compilation of audio visual elements. He's now
promoting 2000 mules as evidence. So there's a few
different things going on here. First of all,
it's great when they fight among themselves,
it weakens them. Generally speaking, we
should encourage it. That's number one.
Number two, when you lose even Kellyanne Conway,
you have to start considering that this might be
the end of the grift to some degree. But at this
point, Trump won't let go of this until he dies.
It's just and we don't know how long he's going
to live, but he is clearly not going to let go
of this false claim that he actually won and
that no one around him was really saying that
you lost. He is going to stick with this until he
dies. He had the opportunity, as I've said before,
to come out of the pandemic, easily, be
reelected. Okay. All he had to do was say, folks.
COVID is real. COVID is scary. And we
as Americans are going to come together.
We're going to be patriotic. We're going to have
Trump masks. We're going to have American flag
and MAGA masks. I'm going to be wearing them. We
should all wear them. We're going to deal with
this better than anybody. We've got the best
doctors and we've got the best university. You
know, we just might take that approach. And
we need to give our medical community time
to develop the treatments and vaccines
that they are going to develop.
Let's do it. Let's do it together. That's
all Trump had to do. The left would have done
it. The right would have gone with it if their
cult leader said it. Instead, he was divisive.
He would blatantly shun and ignore public health
precautions. He almost ended up dead. I mean,
look at how seriously sick with COVID he ended
up being. He would talk about injecting bleach.
He would attack Dr. Fauci. He would talk
about China, you know, on and on and on.
He could have easily been reelected if he
just took it even slightly seriously and
said I am going to be the best on COVID. Not 15
cases will soon be zero, not ignore everything,
not we need our freedom or any of this stuff.
Just follow the protocols. We're going to get
through this. And he couldn't do it. It's sort of
like when he was given the softballs of denouncing
Cunanan or denouncing white supremacy and Nazis
and instead blames both sides or says he doesn't
know about it or doubles down or whatever the case
may be. This guy was given these these were just
teed up for him to knock out of the park and he
couldn't do it. And now the situation he's in
is he is going to take to his grave the lie that
he actually won the 2020 election. If you think
that there is anything that would get him
to admit, I just genuinely lost to Biden. I
don't know what it would be, but let me know
what you think could get him to admit that